hi I'm faith Ellington hi I'm Beth
autumn oh we're gonna talk to you about
the white board so white board is a
digital freeform canvas for creative
collaboration and what we're doing is
trying to move beyond the analog
whiteboard and create a new space we're
a multidisciplinary team can do their
best work together whether they're in
the same room or across the planet from
each other so we'll just jump right in
here so what I have here is this is a
white board with an entire project so
you can imagine where we've done the
timeline we've kind of worked on the
market opportunity from the product
management side the design sprint the
team has looked at what they're gonna do
all in the week we've talked about
distribution so all of these things kind
of are like a project room or a working
space where the team gets together all
of the whiteboards are saved in the
cloud automatically and you can just get
access to all of them you can share them
with anyone on the team that needs
access so as an example we'll jump into
our research brainstorming so what we've
been doing is a study on decision-making
and we've talked a lot about the
different things and as we've been going
through this collaboratively we're
talking for example about the past
research and validating the decision
making process and so as we've looked at
this we've realized this is actually not
what we need this flow to be but this is
a artifact that's just like an image so
you can see that our pa'dar it's kind of
identified here's where we need to fix
it so the white board has of course ink
like a physical whiteboard but it also
has sticky notes
it has lightweight reactions and a bunch
of other digital assets that you can use
so we're gonna take this image and we're
gonna use the wand and what we're gonna
do is convert this directly into digital
ink so this is awesome this is now inked
now we can erase and make changes so if
we've realized that the decision-making
process actually looks a little bit
different we can collaborate on this
together
directly in the whiteboard so there are
a lot of different things that you can
use whiteboard for we have a lot of
different activities around that so we
hope that you will be able to use
whiteboard to help your teams
collaborate an entirely new way thank
you